Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
So today's guest is Professor
Ricardo Vinuesa.
Ricardo is currently a Professor
of Aerospace Engineering at the
University of Michigan, where he
leads research at the
intersection of machine
learning, fluid mechanics,
turbulence, and artificial
intelligence.
Before joining Michigan, he was
a professor at KTH Royal
Institute of Technology in
Stockholm, one of Europe's
leading engineering
universities, and he built an
internationally recognized
research program focused on
turbulent flow control and
data-driven methods for fluid
mechanics.
He's definitely established
himself as one of the leading
researchers looking into this.
And one of the topics that we
bring on today, of course, is
around like explainable AI,
causality, reinforcement
learning, reduced order
modelling, and of course the
topic of the moment foundation
models for fluid mechanics.
He, along with people like Steve
Brunton, has done a lot to really
educate the community, also the
public in terms of these fluid
mechanics and how machine
learning can be used for.
It's really, he's got some great
YouTube videos and explanations.
And what I particularly enjoy
about his work is he doesn't
just ask whether AI can make
predictions faster.
He's looking at the question,
can AI help us to understand the
mechanics of turbulence and to
ultimate accelerate scientific
discovery itself.
So, you know, in this
discussion, which as with any of
them, is never long enough to
fully cover everything, you
know, we dived into some of the
bigger questions facing CFD
today.
So you know whether fluid
mechanics will have its ChatGPT
moment, how close are we to
foundation models can be
generalized across different
flow problems, and why he's
actually more optimistic about
that possibility than than ever
before.
As I mentioned before, the
explainable AI causality,
understanding where they come
from.
Can you explain how AI is
getting to it?
And one of the things that we
also look about is focusing on
the role of reinforcement
learning in terms of
optimization and control and not
just using AI as a pure
predictor.
And then towards the end, we, we
sort of zoom out and talk about
the future of the field, agentic
AI, autonomous scientific
discovery, and also how
universities should be adapting
education given that AI is
changing the whole landscape.
So I, I think this is one of
these conversations that, you
know, I learned a lot from it
and, and I hope you do too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode with Professor Vinuesa.
Thanks very much for agreeing to
do this.
You are definitely on the list.
Of people who everyone says, oh,
you should be speaking to him.
You know, I read the papers, I
see stuff.
And you're the sort of person
where when I read the paper, I
was like, yeah, I really should
have thought of that.
That's a really good idea.
So, yeah, thank you.
No thanks for having me.
It's a real pleasure.
And yeah, looking forward to the
conversation.
So maybe we could get straight
into it, which is the, I guess
the hot conversation now.
Which has only got more intense.
Is this foundation models?
You know, can we somehow make a
model that could?
You know, compute any fluid
flow, whether it's, you know, a
geometry variation, A boundary
condition.
Where do you think we are along
that journey and how close?
How close do you think we are?
To to get in there.
Yeah, I think few years ago I
would have probably given a
different answer, but things are
changing quickly in a in a good
way.
And I think we're getting closer
to having and it all depends on
the type of question that you
want to answer, right.
What type of predictions and
what level of accuracy do you
want to use the systems for
design, Do you want to use the
systems for, for scientific
insight?
And of course what quantities do
you want to get with what level
of accuracy?
So there's many possible
questions and directions to go
into.
But in general, I think that
we're getting pretty close to
having systems that can perform
very well even for quite
complicated quantities and quite
some nuanced phenomena on on our
system.
Especially because depending on
how you define your model, and
depending on the type of
question that you may be
interested in answering, you
don't really need to mimic all
the physics of the real system.
You might just focus on a subset
of questions or a subset of
mechanisms that could be
represented encapsulated in a
smart way.
And that's basically what your
model does, and not necessarily
all the intricate interscale
mechanisms that give rise to
those particular phenomena.
So yeah, I think we're getting
closer to having systems that
truly can give us the right
accuracy, the right performance
in in quite challenging
problems.
Yeah.
So I'm intrigued to know what's
changed your mind.
We said a few years ago you
would have given a different
answer.
Can you pinpoint anything that
has, yeah, changed over the past
few years that's changed that?
There's a couple of things.
The first one is we realised
that we could identify those key
mechanisms pretty well in quite
complex systems using causality,
explainability.
So not just in idealised
versions of the whole flow or in
reduced-order representations,
but in really full fidelity high
order versions of the system, we
could really interrogate the
data, identify what are the
mechanisms that are the most
important and focus on those for
control, for modelling.
So I think those almost
surprising capabilities of this
explainability and causal
frameworks to really
characterize the systems has
been one big pillar.
And the other one, the
performance of some of the
generative deep learning
methods, especially in the last
few years, diffusion, flow
matching, conditional latent
diffusion, these systems are
really capable of generalizing
to an extent that I mean not so
long ago I would say that it was
not really possible.
There's still quite some more to
do and there needs to be some
smart way of formulating these
problems in order to achieve
real generalization, but I would
say that that we are really in a
stage where things are pretty
impressive.
Maybe you could explain, pardon
the pun, what you mean by
explainable AI.
Yeah, that's a, that's a good a
good question.
So what we mean with the systems
and what constitutes an
explanation and even the, the,
you know, the, the grammar and
the definition changes a little
bit depending on the, on the
field you have explainable AI,
explainable deep learning
interpretability.
So there's different kind of
flavours to it.
But the way that I use this term
explainable deep learning would
be kind of assessing for a
particular model what features
of your input matter the most to
the prediction of that model.
So really identifying kind of
like in a feature attribution
sense, what, what, which ones of
those components of the input
really matter to your output.
And why is that interest in the
context of high dimensional
chaotic engineering systems?
Because if you create a model,
an input output model, where I'm
just going to give you an
example.
If I have the wing of an
aircraft and I really want to
see what flow motions are really
affecting the most the drag,
well, then I can create a model
which given the flow, it just
predicts the drag on the wing.
And that's a predictive model
that hopefully performs
reasonably well.
But if I use this explainability
methods on that model, then I
can go point by point and really
identify which points are
contributing the most to the
drag on that wing.
And that idea can really allow
us to identify volumes of
importance of importance for
that particular question, for
the drag in this case.
And what we have found is 2
interesting things.
One is by using these
explainability tools, we realize
that the classical approaches to
study turbulence and people have
been looking at vortices,
streaks, Reynolds stresses, many
other quantities, right?
In fact, when people want to
show off a bit and they do a
very nice CFD visualisation,
very colourful visualisation,
they will show you lambda-2,
right, or something similar.
They show you vortices because
it's very spectacular and it's
very turbulent.
And what we realise with our
methods is that the vortices
don't matter so much actually,
at least for the friction and
for the drag.
They matter for other things,
but not for the stuff that you
are trying to show them for.
And the reason is the fact that
you can see something does not
mean that it's important.
You simply can't see it.
And a lot of the turbulence, a
lot of the turbulence research
has been a bit misled by what
you could see in experiments,
which of course it has been very
helpful and it has been very
illustrative.
But sometimes you need to step
away a bit from the physical
intuition and just simply
interrogate the data in a more
diagnostic way and let the data
tell you what matters and what
doesn't matter.
So what we've found is the
classical approaches to
turbulence research.
They were only telling a part of
the story.
So in different regions, close
to the wall, the the Reynolds
stresses were important.
Farther away, the streaks were
important.
Farther away there were all the
Reynolds stresses that were
important.
So the classical views were not
wrong because obviously, you
know, there's a lot of time and
effort.
They brought it to it.
They were just telling part of
the story, right?
Like the three blind men and the
elephant.
They were, you know, giving
different partial views of what
the elephant look like.
But all the classical
perspectives together is what
actually comes close to what we
identify with our explainability
methods.
And why are we so sure that
these methods are giving us
something that is interesting
and physical?
Because when we devise control
mechanisms, when we manipulate
the flow to diminish the
presence of these mechanisms
that we identify, that's when we
get the highest drag reduction.
So it's not just that purely we
can find nice colourful volumes
of structures is that those
structures in a causal way are
actually affecting the drag in
this case the most.
And they are tackling those
structures is really looking at
the root cause of the drag, so
the disease and not the symptom.
And that's why we think that
this is really a good way to
look at these mechanisms and not
only from kind of controlled
perspective or from a
satisfactory knowledge point of
view, also from a modelling
point of view, because those
mechanisms are the ones that
contain the crucial information
if you want to be a good model
for that phenomenon.
So how do you see the the
challenge that I still be not
got my head around which is the
following.
If we assume that for a
foundational model or you know,
surrogate model, we're assuming
that we have lots of data of
wings of cars, of buildings,
etcetera.
At least today, you know, most
of those have, you know, a
decent error to what is the real
turbulence, what is the real
flow?
And you're asking the model to
learn it.
And sometimes the data comes
from different sources.
You know, the wing may have been
done with this turbulence model,
The car may have done with this.
So how do you see the foundation
model?
Is it ultimately yeah.
Do we have to train on DNS?
But then we can't train on DNS
because it will just be too
expensive.
Do you need some DNS? I
still feel like the foundation
model is ultimately going to not
be as good as people think.
Yeah, because no, I totally see
your your point.
And I think here the key is
going back a bit to the one of
the first questions, what do we
want this model for, right?
And I mean, I don't think that
we are trying to build these
models to replace DNS, right?
I mean we're not going to
because that computationally
would not really make sense,
right?
So I think that we're trying to
build these models to either
accelerate design and
optimization and or achieve some
sort of scientific insight in
our system.
So how can we handle data from
different fidelities and
different modalities?
That's something that in what
we're building in my group,
we're trying to embed the
uncertainty quantification with
active learning loops in a sense
that we know that not all all
our data is of the same
fidelity.
When we are trying to generalize
and we're trying to produce data
for new cases, the system will
tell us, look for this
particular case that you're
trying to produce data in some
latent representation, your
uncertainty is very high.
So you should probably go back
and if you know, if you're
trying to do a helicopters,
well, your helicopter data is
actually pretty bad.
So you should be there, have
higher fidelity or, you know,
run more experiments or really
improve your model there.
And I think that's one strength
actually that we can
progressively keep improving our
model as new data becomes
available.
Now your data for helicopters is
pretty bad for what, right,
Because it depends on what
you're trying to do.
And here is when we need to be a
bit a bit realistic about the
metrics and about the targets
that we want to hit.
So if we are trying to get lift
and drag, right, that's one type
of accuracy and one type of
model.
If we're trying to get the
spectrum right and all the
interscale mechanisms, right,
then that's a different type of
model, right?
So I think in that sense,
depending on the type of
approach and the type of
figurative that we want to
achieve, we may have to resort
to different data sets and
different ways of assessing the
error and the uncertainty of our
systems.
Yeah, no, I, I agree.
I think the there'll be probably
one side of the community that
happily uses, you know, Reynolds
averaged or even panel methods
or or or lower and are, you
know, quite comfortable with
models that are not of DNS
accuracy.
But yeah, yeah.
On the other hand, I, I, I can
imagine just as companies spend
a fortune constantly trying to
get to higher and higher
fidelity CFD that maybe the
models will, you know, go with
it.
One question, because I think
some of your background, you
know, was on, I guess, would it
be fair to say like reduced
order modelling and and some of
that side 2, maybe a more like
lay audience?
I'm not saying everyone
listening to this is a lay
audience.
That's quite the opposite.
But there are some people who
are maybe not as grounded in all
the latest common question I get
is, well, machine learning is
just reduced order modelling.
How would you chart the
evolution, you know, from like
what people would call ROMs
before to machine learning?
And what is it about modern
machine learning that separates
it from reduced-order modelling?
Unless you classify them as to
say.
Yeah.
No, that's a good question.
Depends a little bit on what
you're trying to do with your
machine learning, right, Because
also machine learning is a quite
broad area.
So, I mean, and we have some
work that we've done before on
machine learning for CFD.
So how should you or what are
the areas where machine learning
can help CFD?
And this is work that I did with
my friend Steve Brunton some
years ago where we found three
areas.
We found accelerate DNS,
improve models, both RANS and
LES and improve reduced-order
models or surrogate models.
And, and, and, and that's if we
are thinking of machine learning
for CFD, something that we made
quite clear at the time, this is
4 years ago was that machine
learning in principle would not
replace CFD.
It's not about, and I think that
many people when they think
machine learning for CFD,
they're thinking automatically
replacing CFD, right.
I, I don't think that it's
really about replacing CFD, but
rather complementing and
helping.
So reduced-order modelling would
be just one area within all the
spectrum of possibilities for
machine learning can help just
within CFD, but we can also
think about control and
optimization where this
fantastic reinforcement learning
work, for example, on really
finding new controller
strategies.
So it's very broad, but I would
say that if we focus on on
surrogate models, traditional
models, one key has been the
possibility of handling well,
nonlinearities in your in your
model development, right in your
surrogate.
And of course POD, DMD, I mean, they're
mostly linear, although you can
have nonlinearities in there.
But having neural network based
compression at scale, which is
what you can have now with
modern autoencoder
architectures that really allows
you to have very impressive
compression rates, right.
So quite some capability to to
distill the essential physics of
your system.
And something that we found also
in some of our work is in, I
mean, autoencoders are good at
compressing, right?
Compressing anything, images of
cats and dogs and images of turbulent
flows if you wish.
But turbulent flows, they're
images, their flow fields, they
contain much more information.
They're much richer than cats
and dogs, right?
There's a spectrum, there's a
range of scales.
So you should somehow, when you
compress, you should somehow
disentangle the latent
representation, because if you
do that and you can use beta-
VAEs, you can use hierarchical
priors.
There's different ways to do
that disentanglement, but that
really allows you to encapsulate
in different latent
representations and different
latent vectors, different
physical phenomena of your
problem.
And that's going to be more
effective from the
interpretability point of view
of your surrogate system, but
also from a predictive point of
view.
If you want to make predictions
in in the latent space, that
disentanglement is actually
going to be quite, quite
helpful.
So, yeah, I mean, I guess it was
a bit of a long answer to your
question, but machine learning
is not just reduced-order
modelling.
Let's say that there's many
other things that one can do and
within reduced-order modelling
that, you know, capability of
really having autoencoders at
scale and disentangling the
latent representations has been
quite critical.
And also Transformers, that's
another, well dimension let's
say, or another topic, which
also has helped in building the
temporal dynamics of these reduced-order
systems.
I mean, where do you see?
At least my impression has been
that even though the turbulent
modelling started off as being
one of the the big focuses of
the fluids community, it does
seem to have slightly petered
out a little bit and the focus
has shifted a little bit more to
the surrogate modelling, to the
sort of reduced-order modelling.
Is that something that you've
also noticed?
And do you think that's just
because of a lack of progress?
Do you think it's because the,
you know, the improvements?
I'm just wondering if how you've
seen that?
Yeah, no, that's another good
point.
I think that so turbulence
modelling can be done in
different ways.
And One Direction that has been
adopted by many people has been
to start where more classical
approaches to turbulence model
modelling start.
Basically to which in a way is
just making an empirical
assumption of how the, you know,
the Reynolds stresses need to
behave.
To some extent.
There is some empirical
assumption, more or less
sophisticated and then try to
use machine learning systems to
continue from there.
So in, in other words, to fit
coefficients on classical
models, right?
And well, that's not maybe the
most revolutionary thing, right?
Because if you do that, and
that's what many people have
done.
And I think that's why a bit of
the ML community could have got
a bit disappointed with ML for
fluids, because they were using
ML to adjust coefficients in two
turbulence models that have
been around for decades and
which have based on assumptions
that are a bit crude, perhaps,
right.
But for a reason, they were
crude because there were not
other approaches to, to
modelling that were, you know,
computationally possible at that time.
So I think that could be why
there has been a bit of slow
down.
But at the same time, I've seen
some promising approaches.
I mean, I'm, I'm a bit of a fan
of reinforcement learning.
I've, I've been developing many
methods within reinforcement
learning for control, for
optimization and also for
modelling.
We have some, some projects on
reinforcement learning for
modelling and there's other
groups who are doing great
things in this space.
And I think that the idea is why
start with a model that has been
around for, you know, 20305060
years and try to adjust those
coefficients when we can maybe
take one step back.
So instead of asking my machine
learning model to say for the
Smagorinsky model, what should be
my coefficient, Can you find it
to, to, or even say to my
machine learning model or just
find the subgrid-scale tensor to
be able to fit the statistics of
this this particular channel or
particular flow?
Maybe we can be a bit more
abstract and say, look, I don't
know what the mean flow or the
fluctuations will look like in
this particular case.
I, I don't know what happened.
I've never run this wing or this
aircraft, but what I know is
that turbulence is characterized
by certain energy transfer
mechanisms across scales, and
that energy goes in this
direction and there is an inverse
cascade.
And there's certain phenomena
that need to be true from a
spectral point of view.
And from a mechanistic point of
view, whatever your model is and
whatever the forcing term that
you get each step from your
reinforcement learning or
whatever optimizer that you're
using, just respect those
physical constraints.
Because my flow needs to be
physically correct.
And physically correct does not
mean this is your mean flow.
You need to adjust to this mean
flow because that's a circular
argument, then you need the mean
flow, right?
But rather not only a circular
argument, it's some more, it's a
much more constraining goal to
fit the statistics right.
But something a bit more
flexible, such as making sure
that the energy fluxes are
correct step by step is
something that is less impose
imposing.
And it's also something that is
a bit more manageable for a for
a system for an optimization
system to to be able to adapt
step by step such that those
fluxes are OK.
So I think the second direction
of making statements that are a
bit more general and still
correct from a physical point of
view, that could be more
promising to develop more.
I mean, one of the things that
I've started contemplating, and
I'm interested to see if you've
been the same is for for a while
I was only thinking about, you
know, the machine learning,
either in the context of
learning what the turbulent
viscosity should be or, or more
broadly, what a surrogate model,
you know, should be in terms of
a transformer based or some
neural operator or, or whatever.
And the criticism has been that
it's, how can it match the, the
brains, you know, the thought
process that, that, that we've
had.
And I saw at an event, I was at
the British Library, there was
an AI, somebody organized UKTC,
the Turbulence Consortium in the
UK.
And it was Luca Magri from
Imperial was organizing with
some people.
And there was a Professor,
Michael Leschziner, who, you
know, is a sort of pioneer of
turbulence modelling developed with
Brian Launder, you know, all
these Reynolds-stress models.
And, and he rightly said to me
that he was, you know, gently
wondering how could these AI
models, you know, know, all
these things that, that, that
they've done.
And then I started to think, is
this really, and I don't know if
the capabilities today where the
agentic thing comes in because
in some ways is it more
realistic to ask an LLM to
reason through the process of
how you would develop a turbulence
model and have links in to
software tools to explore it and
go through that reasoning
process and reinforcement
learning.
Then just say, hey, try and find
me the the latent representation
of this.
Do you know what I mean?
Do you think almost the
scientific discovery that piece
is the better route rather than
just expecting machine that is?
So I don't know if I've
explained that, but.
That makes perfect sense.
I think it's, it's a very fair
question and we are trying to
well to really first of all
understand the potential of
agentic systems and 2nd, we
are learning to ask the right
questions to these systems.
I think before getting into
that, I think that a preliminary
point is what is the right way
to represent the data that we as
engineers and scientists in you
know, higher order chaotic
complex systems.
What is the right, the right way
to represent the data and such
an exploration from these agents
or whatever or, or any
scientist, what's the right
platform to represent the data,
right?
Because there's quite some work
on LLMs to do this and to try to
achieve discovery, whatever we
define by discovery.
But you know, if we think of the
of turbulent flows, of course,
this is these are systems that
are having the broadband in
terms of the spectrum, they have
multiple scales, multiple energy
fluxes.
Perhaps text is not the right
way to represent this very
complex data, right?
And perhaps using LLMs directly
and text as a platform to try to
explore complex questions in
this space might not be the the
most suitable approach.
And what we have been thinking
and exploring is what if we can
create latent representations
that are particularly attuned to
represent important properties
of these turbulent-flow systems.
And, and that's an approach that
we have been developing in our
group where we are trying to
build a foundation models, kind
of latent representations of
very broad ranges of cases such
that we can use those latent
spaces to explore the, the, you
know, the, the complexity of
these, of these turbulent flows.
One guiding principle has been
information, information fluxes,
causality.
So what if we can create latent
spaces where causal relations
are maximized or where the
disentanglement of the variables
is such that I can very easily
explore physical mechanisms
through that latent space.
And I believe and again, this is
stuff that we are very excited
about because we are we're
developing it with pretty
promising results that using a
agentic systems in that latent
representation might be a good
way to achieve discovery.
So in, in other words, I have a
data from wings aircraft flows
in cities a compressors and
these are very different fluid
mechanics problems.
But if we find smart way to
compress all that data and
express it in the same latent
representation, so now suddenly
I don't have a wing and a city,
but everything is expressed in
the same language on the same
table.
And then I can allow this
agentic systems to explore this
latent space very efficiently.
Because of course this AI
systems can't really find one
side compress everything so
much.
I can find patterns across cases
that might not be obvious in in
the physical space for us humans
and neither for agents, right.
Because finding a connection
between a wing and a city, I
mean, yeah, maybe if I look like
that, I see a vortex that looks
similar.
But you know, it's, it's a bit
more anecdotal, anecdotal than
anything.
But when I express everything in
that space and then I can do
that automatic and autonomous
exploration with these agents,
then I can try to get insight.
Then I can try to find causal
relations that are key in that
latent space.
And then our job with
explainability tools is to
express that insight in the
latent space, which is
completely non understandable
for us back in the physical
space and say, look, this is
what insight looks like in the
latent space.
That means that this vortex from
the shear layer of the wing is
actually very similar to this
vortex from the shear layer in
the separation of that building
in the city.
So that's actually a common
mechanism.
That's interesting.
And I can find that through
compressing, expressing in the
common space, A autonomously
exploring and then going back to
the physical representation.
Yeah, that's, I really like the
I've you've hit the really good
explanation there because this
is something I've been thinking
in my head is and I I'm not, I
need to look into it more to be
completely honest.
But I almost see 2 slightly
different approaches
traditionally, which is 1, which
is kind of what we wrote in this
paper.
We put out recently this idea
that, oh, you, you know, we're
going to run lots of simulations
of planes and cars and cities
and turbo machineries and
basically every single possible
geometry and boundary condition
that we see in real life, which
feels in some ways the more
logical and achievable way.
It's just like you just have to
have a lot of them.
But then the other side is that
actually it doesn't matter
whether it's a plane or a city
or whatever, It's just you're
just trying to learn the flow
physics.
And actually you may massively
have way too much information by
trying to do all possible ones.
Which then I thought, couldn't
you achieve this?
Do you really need wings?
Couldn't you just create lots of
random shapes with lots of
random boundary conditions?
And as long as you take every
possible consequence of shear
flow and pressure gradients, it
doesn't actually matter if it
looks like a plane because
you're just trying to learn the
physics.
That's a very good question, I
would say.
I mean, that can be helpful
because what you want is to be
able to explore such a latent
representation very broadly, you
know, and that you can really
investigate many configurations
and calculations and so on.
At the end, well, we want to
revert back to something that we
can understand, right?
And then probably having some
random shapes with some random
pressure gradient and curvature
distributions would be helpful
for the exploration because that
would allow us to identify
different mechanisms that
probably we haven't seen just
because they were not ideal
dynamic, but maybe they were
helpful for other things.
But probably in our data sets,
we want to have shapes that
we're familiar with and
applications that we're familiar
with just for the kind of
interpretation point of view, so
such that we can connect it.
But from the latent space
generation, yes, the most the
more diverse and the more crazy,
the better.
In fact, what what we are doing,
what we are building is systems
that the agent not only does the
exploration but also generates
new geometries by itself.
So we have this problem that we
like very much and we're having
a pre print coming out very soon
on this.
So it's basically two cylinders, to
the keep it simple for now, but
it's 2 cylinders with different
radii and different separations.
And we just want the our system
agentic AI with a foundation
model system to to explore the
wake of this tandem cylinder
arrangement and just look at the
recovery of the wake.
And then what this does is,
well, in order to do that, and
this is trained on few cases,
right?
It's not trained on many cases,
but I need to explore the whole
space, right?
So these agents, what they do
is, oh, but I need to look at
this configuration and calculate
my wake characteristics and
internal quantities and you
know, displacement thickness,
momentum thickness, okay, I know
this.
But then I need to look at a
different case and a different
case and a different case.
And then it starts to
sequentially understand what the
scaling of the wake recovery
looks like as a function of the
parameters of your problem.
And you haven't not had to
create hundreds of cases.
You only have to create a few
cases.
But it's the foundation model
combined with the agent that is
doing that autonomously is doing
the discovery for you by
identifying what regions are
important and creating and
generating new data in those
regions.
In those regions.
I think that's where we are
going so that we can even find a
discovery of cases that we don't
even think of because, because
we have been looking at patterns
influenced by the past history,
right?
And kind of like the need of
applications, but autonomously
exploring the whole space as
agents can do.
They can really multiply the the
the insights and new solutions
and new mechanisms that we can
actually discover.
And and that's why I'd feel and
I'm guilty of this myself, that
we are still probably too, too
much splitting the fluids task
or the data generation task from
the machine learning task.
And so, you know, I'll be
transparent for the data sets
that I've typically generated,
they have been kind of segmented
a little bit for practical
reasons, for people reasons.
So you're like, right, Well, you
know, you have a bunch of
meetings, you decide what you're
going to do.
You then kick off the data
generation exercise, you
generate lots of data, and then
you train the model.
And where, as you say, what you
really want to be doing is
constantly them being in a loop
together and only generating the
data it needs to generate.
But I don't know if you found
this in your work, but one of
the problems is that even the
machine learning frameworks are
typically not even written in
the same language that the data
generation is.
And doing that on a big HPC
machine and training and
translating information, it's,
it's quite challenging and maybe
brings the topic that, you know,
we briefly discussed before we
started recording, which is this
fluid community, computer
science, ML community.
How have you seen those two
communities come closer?
Still not close enough, You
know, how how have you assessed
this?
And, and, and to be fair, you
have done a great deal.
And to be fair with people like
who you collaborate, Steve
Brunton of of trying to, you
know, bring a little bit
together.
But yeah, how how do you see
those two communities at the
moment?
Well, thank you.
Thank you so much.
First, I think the problem that
has happened for a while and
still present, although probably
getting a bit better, is that
they have been a bit
disconnected in really
understanding the the depths of
the problems in fluid mechanics.
And perhaps the fluid mechanics
community, when trying to adopt
ML methods, has been sometimes
a bit naive in just.
Adopting very vanilla
architectures and maybe giving
up a bit too quickly without
fully understanding.
So, you know, if the mechanics
community is guilty in part, and
I think what has happened also
from the CS community is that,
you know, I mean aerodynamics
from I am at the aerospace
engineering department right
here in Michigan.
We train engineers for many
years to understand the
mechanics, aerodynamics,
structures and many other
things.
But of course fluid mechanics is
a big part of it.
So you can't understand all the
complexities of fluid mechanics,
you know, in the course of 2-3
months, right?
Because there is a lot to look
at.
These are very entangled
problems and sometimes the
questions and the problems that
we have in fluid mechanics are
not what typically the CS
community has looked at
necessarily.
Because you know, the type of
data that has been used in the
CS community to develop methods
is not necessarily of the same
characteristics as the fluid
mechanics data.
And this is very rich data with
a very broadband spectrum, multi-
scale.
This is really, really complex
physics, right?
So maybe looking at the MSE is
not the right metric, right?
Because this only tells you a
very, very partial view of the
story.
And maybe even having a model
that predicts the MSE, well,
that might be useless in some
cases, right?
We maybe want other things.
Maybe we just want to look at,
you know, systems that predict
separation, right or that
predict certain aspects of the
mixing or maybe, you know,
certain structures, certain
mechanisms as I was mentioning
before for, you know, for a drag
producing mechanisms.
So it could be that for my
purpose, if I want to reduce
drag, having a good MSE is
actually counterproductive
because the MSE is going to
drive me to certain events,
which may be very energetic and
they may be contributing a lot
to the MSE, but not so relevant
towards the drag generation,
which is the stuff that I want
to, you know, focus on in my
application.
Therefore, a model with a much
worse MSE but getting the error
right in the right mechanisms is
way better, right?
So I think the this type of this
type of interaction is what is
really going to help us build
more useful models, at least
from the fluid mechanics
community.
And of course, this is not just
for fluid mechanics.
This is applicable to any area
of, of science, right?
But of course, I can speak, you
know, with more depth on the
fluid mechanics problems because
what you want, and this is
another question, you know,
let's build a foundation model.
Let's build a big ML system for
fluids, OK.
But for fluids for what, right.
I mean, within fluids and within
aerodynamics and within
combustion, I mean, there are so
many questions that we can look
at and probably the model that
you build is going to be quite
different for all those
questions, right?
So I think that's really
understanding in more depth what
the fluid mechanics problems
require.
What are the questions that we
have?
don't have?
How to build models that can
really effectively tackle those
questions, that can be a much
more effective use of
everybody's time, basically.
Where do you sit on the debate
around a data-driven versus
physics driven models?
You know, again, the usual
criticism from people who are
maybe from a fluid background
is, you know, any of these
data-driven approaches cannot
guarantee mass conservation,
energy conservation.
They can't guarantee, you know,
we should be implicitly or
explicitly imposing, which I
guess is where some of the PINNs,
you know, things started.
But then the successes seem to
have been not as strong in the
sort of physics informed,
inspired, conditioned.
So yeah, where where do you sit
on that side of the fence?
That's, well, that's, that's a
big question, right?
Of course you need to, you need
to use any physical information
that you have about your system
when building your models,
right.
But if you just use the
equations and nothing else, then
you're building a numerical
solver, right, with a
data-driven numerical solver.
And if you just use data, then
you are a problem, you know, be
being very wasteful because
there's a lot of information
that you have about your system
that you need to relearn.
Like, you know that your system
has certain symmetries, certain
conservation properties.
If you don't embed that in your
system, well, first of all, your
model will be wrong because you
will never be, you know,
conservative exactly right or as
exactly as possible.
But second, even if it's a very,
it's a system that is very
conservative, you have to learn
that right.
So you need to use data and
compute to get to that point.
And of course, that's something
that you knew from the
beginning.
So it's not very smart to to
waste that information.
So like with everything in life,
right, no extreme is going to be
optimal.
And I think that both extremes
have been explored and we have
learned a lot from it.
To me, being able to use
symmetries, conservation laws in
your problems.
If you're trying to solve for
several velocity components, I
mean, do you know that there is
the flow is incompressible, Do
you know that you can use
incompressibility to get the
velocity component or use that
in the way that you're building
your system?
But also going back to an idea
that I like very much, this
whole explainability, causality
mechanisms.
If we know these things, why
don't we try to build systems
that are really focused on this?
And one example is, let's
imagine that I want to create a
system that predicts very well
the acoustic field of an airfoil
or a drone, right?
Because drones can be very
noisy.
I want to be able to control the
acoustic field, the noise
produced by this drone.
Why don't I use some of these
causality explainability methods
to identify and pinpoint the
mechanisms producing the noise?
And by mechanisms, I'm talking
about flow regions interacting
with each other in physical
space.
And then when I build a
predictive model, I don't look
at the, you know, trying to get
neither just the governing
equations like in a PINN way or
just use data to predict the
flow fields.
But rather, why don't I try to
predict just those structures,
those mechanisms that produce
the acoustic field in that way,
you're really encapsulating in
those structures a lot of
information.
And that's where I think that
one can have computational
savings with respect to, you
know, doing a much more resolved
simulation.
Because those structures
producing the acoustic field are
the result of a lot of, you
know, interscale energy
interactions that you need to
resolve when you do a DNS.
But the model, I mean, once that
DNS is run, those structures
that are producing the acoustic
field and so on, that the result
of those interactions, right?
So you don't need to re simulate
them all the time.
Once you know what the
mechanisms are, you can try to
develop models that target those
physical mechanisms precisely
and not everything else.
Of course.
That's why I repeat, sometimes I
want a model for what?
If your model is for the
acoustic field, then my advice
would be, well, identify what
are the mechanisms producing the
acoustic field and try to get
those very well, right?
Because probably you will not
get a perfect model, but you
will get something that is
pretty accurate and pretty
efficient because you don't need
to solve everything.
But if your goal is to have
something that gets the acoustic
field very well and the gusts
and the turbulence and the heat
transfer well, then you need a
multi physics DNS, right?
Then, then you need to solve
everything.
So it depends a little bit on
what you want and of course,
embedding that physical insight
in your model, not as equations,
but as mechanisms that you can
then, you know, recreate with
your system.
I think that that's a pretty
promising way to go.
And how from a, you know,
you're, you're obviously a
professor at university.
What do you think?
What's the role of academia in
this, focusing more on like the
students in the education side,
you know, do you try and team up
more with the computer science
departments?
Is it a matter of swapping
people over like, but but then
equally, I guess you don't want
to not teach some of your
existing content.
So how do you balance getting
rid of some content, bringing
new ones in?
That's that's a key question.
And we're having many
discussions around this.
For example, here in Michigan, I
mean, we're having a lot of
conversations around our new
curriculum and how to well adapt
to AI era, LLM-based era.
So we're having many
conversations around this.
So first of all, we have a very
good interaction with Los Alamos
National Lab.
We actually have a bunch of Los
Alamos scientists sitting on our
campus and working with them
daily and interacting with them
constantly.
So we really get access to that
synergy and that cooperation
with computer scientists, which
are world class, right?
So with with really incredible
computational facilities.
So I think such an interface and
such a close connection is, is
essential.
But the other thing is from the
educational point of view, we
need to be of course aware of
the fact that students have
access to LLMs, right?
And and that, you know, the way
that we teach, the way that we
assess is different from what it
used to be.
But in a way, and this is
conversations that we're having
with my colleagues and I think
that there's quite some
interesting, I'm promising
directions in here.
We, we don't need to necessarily
see this as a disadvantage, but
rather as an opportunity to use
these systems to encourage
students for more exploration,
for deeper, for, for deeper
questions and deeper assessments
of the content almost in a
customized way, right?
So, so I think that rather than
thinking that students are going
to be lazy and just look up
their answers and not think,
rather use these these systems
to help students think in a way.
But do you feel that?
I guess flicking around the
other way, do do computer
science students need to learn
more about the sciences?
You know, there's a lot of like
AI for science.
If the engineers are all
learning some of the computer
science being, then what are the
computer scientists doing?
Is there, is there an equal
thing on the computer science
say hey you all need to be
learning some science domain
because AI is going to do the
some of the core CS stuff, you
know?
I was, well, I'm, I can tell you
that there is, I mean, there is
an increase of enrollment of
students in, in areas like
aerospace engineering and, and
part of it comes from computer
science, although of course the
computer science degrees,
they've been excellent at
adapting to, to new technologies
and new well, developments
within AI for science.
But there is more and more
overlap and more and more, you
know, joint educational programs
across systems and across
engineering disciplines.
And yes, I would, I would agree
completely that if computer
scientists are going to be the
developing AI for science or AI
for engineering methods, then
they're going to need more
background in these, in these
topics.
And that's something that is
really that's multidisciplinary
wealth and and richness is
what's going to bring really
stellar research in the next
years, right?
That 1 is really capable of
finding completely new
directions like the foundation
model and the agent are finding
patterns across data sets that
you would not imagine, right.
When we start to interact in
disciplines at a different
level, we're going to find such
connections that maybe we did
not expect at the beginning.
So one of the things that, you
know, you mentioned a few times
is on the like control and
optimization side of things.
And I feel at least myself a
little bit guilty that I, I'm
always thinking of, you know,
the, the impact of machine
learning or reduced order models
in terms of a predicted
capability.
You know, we can predict this
flow much faster.
But I guess for industry or even
for scientific discovery, but
particularly for industry, it's
almost always a kind of
optimization problem in a way
isn't it's like I need to have
the best design or the lowest
drag or the it's never just a
prediction.
So, So what progress have you
seen with the sort of automatic
differentiation, the the ability
of machine learning to maybe
help advance that optimization
process?
Yeah, I I think that prediction
is important.
It's interesting.
It's not the most impactful
application of machine learning.
It's in optimization and
control.
That's where we can really have
the, the biggest, the biggest
impact.
So as I mentioned before, I, I
worked a lot on reinforcement
learning.
So that's an area where we have
been able to control cases that
were not possible three or four
years ago or at least with this
degree of control authority.
And not only.
So I would say not just from a
purely design point of view of
reducing drag or enhancing
mixing.
I would argue that for
discovery, for really
understanding the mechanisms and
the building blocks of these
physical systems, you can use
optimization and, and, and
reinforcement learning.
For example, I mean, imagine a
turbulent flow where a made-up
turbulent flow where the energy
fluxes are restricted to certain
scales and to certain wave
numbers dynamically, right That
you do it as the flow is running
and, and, and you want to do
that in physical space.
So you want to really affect
certain structures with a
certain forcing.
Well, you are probably going to
have to do it with some
optimization technique.
And reinforcement learning is
good for optimizing systems that
are changing dynamically.
So you you're going to end up
with a with a modified system or
a system where production is
minimized and dissipation is
maximized.
How does a flow like that look
like?
And let me study, let me study
that new flow, right?
I mean, I have created a
completely made-up flow thanks
to optimization.
And now I can look at the
Spectra, I can look at the
structures and learn something
about my problem, right.
So yes, these capabilities with
optimization are key also for
discovery and so for getting
insight.
And going back to your previous
point about how new systems and
differentiable solvers, I mean,
we, we are really having the
chance of solving problems at
scale of this optimization type
of system, which was not
possible before.
And inverse problems where we
can, you know, optimal sensing,
we can really look at optimal
initial conditions and optimal
perturbations really for very,
very challenging configurations.
All of that is possible now
thanks to the scale that we can
achieve with these systems.
So I think that's, yeah, I mean,
prediction is, is good.
It's interesting.
It's only part of the problem.
It's really in the control and
optimization and in the
explainability of those
predictions.
Like, OK, I have predicted very
well in my system, but why are
those predictions happening?
And what are the really
important physics and effects
that I can observe with my
system?
That's that's the stuff that I
think is is is actually
valuable.
So maybe a sort of final
question or, or topic looking
towards the future a little bit.
You, you said right at the
beginning that if, if I had
asked you a few years ago, you'd
have said that we're, we're
actually, you know, further
away.
So if you look forward in time
and let's say to 2030, so 4
years out, yeah, four years out,
where do you think we'll be at?
Do you perceive there being a a
sort of ChatGPT moment in fluid
or do you think it'll be just
more incremental improvements?
Yeah, that's a tough question.
I think one key to go towards
ChatGPT moment in fluids was to
realise that we need a good
latent representations for our
problem.
And I think that now there's
several groups of several people
working in that direction.
So I think we're probably in the
right path.
I would not.
So I don't know if we want to
aim at being having a ChatGPT
situation in fluids, maybe
something beyond maybe something
more than what ChatGPT can can
do.
What I think that we are aiming
at, and I don't know if that
would be in 2030, but I think
that it's actually reasonable to
think that it should happen in
the next years, is more
autonomous discovery, a more
automatic discovery.
So one, I like the, the one
example of how big changes in in
the paradigm of physics have
taken place and of course, well,
relativity departing from more
classical mechanics.
I mean, it takes, if you think
about it, a lot of a lot of
coincidences to line up in order
for that to happen.
And you need someone who is
smart enough and also crazy
enough to propose something very
different.
And of course, Einstein lacked
all the math background to be
able to, you know, develop the
theory of relativity properly.
So he had to learn the math and
interact with the right people
to be able to do this properly.
And then, you know, to have the
right experiments of the of the
solar eclipse to really look at
the deviation of the sunbeams.
And there's some fun stories
about how those measurements
took place because there were
several groups doing the
experiments at the same time,
and they had different types of
problems to really get the
measurements that eventually
corroborated that light was, you
know, displaced by the sun in a
way consistent with relativity.
There's a lot of serendipity in
discovery, a lot of coincidences
lined up, and a lot of human trial
and error to achieve truly
transformative discovery in
science.
And I think that the sort of
systems where we can line up on
the same space, the data from
different disciplines and having
agents systematically probing
and analysing these data sets,
that can really be the way in
which we can accelerate that.
But it's this acceleration of
discovery, which is something
that, you know, many people are
talking about with different
meanings.
And I think it's a little bit
shallow the way that it's been
portrayed sometimes.
To me, what it means is being
able to probe the data and find
patterns in a more systematic
way than what it takes us as
humans to take those leaps.
Because we're it's really
decades and decades and
centuries to line up all those
coincidences necessary for that
leap to happen.
And if we can do this in a way
that is much more autonomous and
much more systematic in that
sense, that can be accelerated,
right?
And this sort of systems I, you
know, I think that we are really
getting there actually.
And, and, and this is not really
about replacing human insight or
human input.
This is really about
accelerating the exploration on
the capability of coming up with
mechanisms with hypothesis with
a really patterns that are non
trivial across across
disciplines and across cases.
So yeah, I think that we're
heading in that direction of
really being able to make
autonomous discovery thanks to
the possibility of compressing
data and interrogating it
systematically in a way.
Yeah, it does seem that there is
this, I would say inflection
point now where I would largely
agree with you, you know, a few
years.
Ago when I.
Started to think about some of
like a foundational model, you
know, it it did for various
reasons just felt quite Yeah,
just like impossible almost.
It would, you know, may still
be, but I I also get the feeling
that there is a, a general
movement of replicating the sort
of ChatGPT success, you
know, the the set.
And this is broader than just
fluids across science, across
physics, across all, you know,
possible disciplines that, you
know, it worked for that which
and, and I'm not I haven't
studied a a great deal, but I,
you know, I know enough to know
that many people thought that it
couldn't be possible, right.
You know, people weren't saying,
oh, ChatGPT Oh yeah, we knew
that was going to come.
You know, it was quite a big
impact and, and it, it was done
at a scale that was larger than
anyone thought possible.
And I, I do have a feel that
made people more ambitious, you
know, and, and think, well, if,
if it could work for that, it,
it could work.
But I do like your argument on
that.
Sometimes you need to look at
things a bit differently because
I have a funny feeling that the
approach that ultimately makes
it may not be the one that is
mainstream today.
You know that that like in all
in science, there's always, it's
always the person who takes a
little bit of a, an odd
direction at the time which
turns out to actually be the
one, you know?
An agent to come up with that
direction, maybe.
But that's what I meant.
Like the, I can totally see how
with humans sort of in the loop,
you know, in, in, in terms of
guiding things, that the maybe
it is ultimately the power of
ChatGPT to find the next
ChatGPT.
You know, that those LLM
technology and the agents and
the way they work together with,
of course, the way that you
structure the data, you know,
may help.
And, and then maybe that's
artificial general intelligence.
And then we can all just, you
know, go and retire and, and,
and chill out.
But yeah, I really appreciate
having the chance to, to, to
chat about this.
What I'm going to do for people
listening or watching is to put
a bunch of links into the, the
comments because there's a few
papers that you alluded to that
are really good, you know, great
reads that talk in more detail
about some of that explainable
AI and some of the work that,
you know, you've done.
So I'll, we'll put them in the
link and highly recommend that
people read through them to go
even deeper than we discussed
now.
But yeah, I, I really appreciate
it.
And I think your work is going
to be seen as a major
contributing factor to hopefully
achieving that ChatGPT moment.
Well, thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Maybe that's a bit optimistic,
the money work, but I appreciate
that much.
And at the end we, we have fun
with what we do.
I think that's kind of like the
key, the key idea and we keep
learning.
So that's that's pretty much it.
Exactly, exactly.
Great.
Thank you so much.